je prépare ma pancarte pour la
manifestation de vendredi
comme des milliers d'autres personnes
sandrine virulent manifestera vendredi
âgée de 20 ans elle milite pour que les
gouvernements donnent le coup de barre
qui contrera le réchauffement climatique
depuis quelques années est possible pour
elle de faire abstraction des nombreuses
nouvelles sombres
à propos de l'avenir de la planète c'est
comme une prise de parole quand on y
pense parce que à chaque jour à chaque
minute il ya des gestes qui sont émis
dans l'atmosphère et on part lundi
l'université
les forêts sont détruits requis quand y
penser il ya encore énormément de
plastique dans le sens qui est déversé
chaque jour on en finit plus c'est
vraiment comme une planète qui peut
donner généralisée sandrine a compris
qu'elle est éco anxieuse ça existe parce
que c'est un sujet qu'on parle de plus
en plus l'environnement l'éco anxiété ne
dit pas un trouble anxieux diagnostiqués
mais la psychologue léonie lemire
théberge constate que de plus en plus de
gens ressentent cette forme d'anxiété
les jeunes peuvent avoir des problèmes à
se concentrer à l'école parce qu'ils
sont toujours envahi par ses pensées là
il peut avoir toutes sortes de
sensations physiques associés le thé
motta est mort car étourdissements qui
sont reliés à l'anxiété on peut faire
des attaques de panique parce qu'on
n'est pas capable comme de ce calme et
par rapport aux sujets selon sept
professeurs l'école a un rôle à jouer
pour apaiser l'anxiété des jeunes la
meilleure façon de réagir dans cette
situation de stress c'est d'abord de son
parler de créer des communautés de
dialogue est aussi de mettre en place
des situations où les jeunes peuvent
être soutenus dans leur élan de
transformation du monde
face à l'engouement ce il y à aussi
l'action sandrine est devenu vegan en
raison de l'importante empreinte
écologique de la viande et pratique le
zéro déchet son écot militantisme
influencé son choix d'études
universitaires tout comme sa décision de
changer d'emploi et l'autre emploi ou gt
y avait énormément mais énormément de
déchets qui étaient générés et qui était
même presque toutes les boîtes de carton
qu'on avait était pas recyclés c'était
juste vraiment pas dans mes valeurs si
ça me semblait de l'anxiété de travail
le ressentir de les confier t c'est
parfois renoncer à fonder une famille
depuis le début du mois des milliers de
jeunes ont signé le pacte pas d'avenir
pas d'enfants dans lequel ils s'engagent
à ne pas avoir d'enfant tant et aussi
longtemps que leur gouvernement ne leur
garantira pas un avenir sécuritaire
sandrine n'a pas complètement fermé
cette porte mais elie pense essayer
d'élever un enfant dans un monde qu'on
sait qu'il va probablement finir à cause
des catastrophes naturelles
mais je vois pas le but et je veux pas
faire souffrir quelqu'un pour ce malgré
les scénarios catastrophes
sandrine garde espoir elle voit les gens
autour d'elle qui font une différence
un geste à la fois et elle croit surtout
dans sa génération qui se soulèvent pour
être la clé du changement ici valérie
michaela bayne radio canada montréal